armored Core 6 has three endings and
each one is more complicated than the
last from Coral to corporate factions to
unexpected AI ghosts there's a lot to
keep track of if you care about the
story Beyond just Gatling gun go so I'm
going to go through each ending and
explain the main points obviously I will
discuss spoilers so if you want to get
each ending before watching this video
go beat the game three times with that
feel free to subscribe if you want more
content like this and I hope you enjoy
before getting to the differences each
ending shares roughly the same starting
circumstances heading into the final
chapter chapter 5 archibus has muscled
out Balaam and taken control of the
massive Coral siphon the vascular plant
being the winners of the war archipus is
trying to collect The Spoils of all the
coral on Rubicon 3. and for a short
explanation of what Coral is the opening
cinematic calls it a powerful fuel
source and data conduit which was poised
to progress Human Society drastically
before it was largely burned in the
fires of Ibis but we also learned that
Coral is an organic self-propagating
substance and that it houses air and her
brothers and sisters air tells us that
our own Consciousness can be scattered
into the coral flow too so it seems that
Coral is some sort of mass or Collective
organism where small pieces gravitate
towards one another
so that is a first look at Coral and the
setting we find ourselves in at the
start of each ending as I said there are
three and the first one I want to look
at right now is ostensibly the most
straightforward it's what happens when
we follow the main plan from our Handler
Walter and bring about the fires of
Raven
the fires of Raven ending has already
started to be referred to as the bad
ending of the game I understand this
since it's kind of planet genocide but
it might be beneficial to also view it
as the default ending it's what happens
when you go along with the plan from
Walter and Carla without changing
anything we begin this ending after
getting bodied by V2 snails Noob
friendly stun Cannon so we start in the
sewers with a message from Walter he
tells us we need to finish the job that
the fires of Ibis started that they were
meant to burn away all the coral but
they failed instead the coral survived
and began growing exponentially now
risking to spill out and contaminate
space
from the first log of Professor nagai
the director of the Rubicon Research
Institute we learned that Coral would be
able to grow out of control in a vacuum
like space and that mutations in this
rapid growth could lead to a collapse
Humanity wouldn't be able to control
nagai initiated the fires of Ibis to
avoid this during a coral growth 50
years ago back in the present Walter
ends his message with the words used as
the game's tagline
[Music]
I have one last job for you
find your freedom
he adds in a plea for us to make our own
choices to find our freedom which we
will see is an ongoing theme in all of
the endings after escaping archibus
forces Carla gives us some more
information how she and Walter are part
of overseer the association of observers
who exist to monitor the coral and burn
it before the collapse came Carla tells
us the plan to Ram The Colony ship xylem
into the vascular plant to set all the
collected Coral Ablaze this ending has
us go along with that plan and doing so
gives us a gauntlet of AC fights First
We Take Out V1 Freud with chatty's help
only to learn that chatty was an AI made
by Carla then we find Rusty attacking
the ship while piloting the steel Haze
or Taos both from the AC's description
in the arena and from what he says we
see that Rusty is an undercover
rubiconian who wants to defend the
planet from being exploited and burned
because of this fight alone it makes
sense why people call this the bad
ending we must kill our one in and only
buddy finally we come to fight error who
is taking control of the planetary
closure satellite to fire at the xylem
air tells us that she must do her Duty
as a rubiconian I.E to not let us super
nuke the planet she comes at us in an
Ibis series AC the ib-07 soul 644
throughout the fight air talks about how
she thought we could have helped develop
the shared potential between humans and
coral she mentions
a shared life
some way of balancing Coral in humans
that would allow both to thrive but she
is our enemy and this Vision stands
against the plan from Walter so we
defeat her and RAM the xylem into the
plan we fly away from the explosion but
Carla had to manually pilot the ship
into its Target Rubicon Burns and
when the storm of fire finally faded
only the ashes of civilization remained
maybe the coral is gone for good this
time or maybe it's Cinders will one day
reignite for now Rubicon is left a dead
planet and a new Calamity is to be
forever remembered the fires of Raven
here the title fires of Raven kind of
replaces the old buyers of Ibis this
obviously draws a parallel between the
two Planet burning events and it kind of
leads me to believe that this Burning
doesn't really solve the problem of
coral just like Ibis failed to fully
burn out Coral why should we think that
the fires of Raven did the job any
better the previous fire was big enough
to Scorch the Stars so I'm pretty
worried that this might have just reset
things the rubiconians have their Planet
burned once again the coral is either
destroyed or severely decimated but we
may have just extended the problem
putting Rubicon once more into the cycle
it went through 50 years ago in this
giant Holocaust of fire did we simply
re-link the flame and delay the
inevitable need for a different solution
as you can maybe tell I am inclined to
think so but it's hard to say for
certain which is not a surprise to
anybody used to from Salt gains either
way there is one more parallel between
the fires it seems we Raven survive
since after the credits we get one final
message from Walter
[Music]
and right the wrongs of the past
story
and I'm grateful
six two one
two one there's nothing left
whatever choices you make now
I just hope you find your true potential
while Walter's words Harbor Beauty we
may have just taken his place faded to
one day return to Rubicon when the coral
swells are we really Unbound Like Walter
says I don't think so I think this
ending points towards no that we are
trapped in the same cycle and that we
didn't actually make any positive change
that will last but I have seen some
people read this ending more
sympathetically so let me know in the
comments if you think differently than
how I presented it
as the foil to fires of Raven we have
the Liberator of Rubicon ending with
Liberator in the name it's not hard to
see why this ending might be called the
good one the basic setup here is the
same we get bamboozled in chapter 4
saved by Carla and confronted with the
plan to Nuke the vascular plant however
in this ending we side with Air instead
of going along with Walter and Carla's
plan air being a coral pulse wave
mutation whatever that means
unsurprisingly doesn't want all the
coral and rubiconian people glass to
high heaven she explicitly calls the
coral her family and brothers and
sisters so opting for another path makes
sense for her and since we are seemingly
the only person who can hear her when
she has made contact with she wants us
to help her find this other path she
says of Walter and Carla that The
Observers
and if they want to burn it to
Extinction both are fair
characterizations Walter and Carla say
their plan is eradication because they
fear exponential Coral growth especially
into space and in Walter's story of The
two scientists the one who delved into
Coral research
that Walter characterized as sins The
Observer is definitely fear Coral
because of the conflict it has driven in
humans the war the fires of Ibis and the
potential for its further growth but air
sees quarrel differently as something
that doesn't have to destroy or be
burned she says I believe in the shared
potential of humanity and the call
how they can possibly coexist in a
harmonious way air asks us to avoid
ramming the coral mass with the xylem to
instead allow for a future where coral
and Humanity can live together in some
unknown way she appeals to our
individuality in making the choice to
help her
I'm not asking Walter's Hound
but Raven the independent mercenary
when we choose to side with air we have
to kill Carla and chatty Carla has a
post-death plan which locks the xylem
into its trajectory but we can still
stop it by attacking the ship itself and
it's kind of odd that the situation
basically ignores the setup in the last
ending where air was able to stop the
ship from going forward without a pilot
like Carla by shooting it with the
closure system in this fight air has
called upon all rubiconians for help
using our name Beyond scorched Skies
Raven fights on so we get to fight
against the xylem's defenses and the
remaining corporate assets with the
rubiconians and one special buddy air
tells us that V4 Rusty was the first to
offer help and he fights with us through
the ship we get a bunch of great quotes
from Rusty in this section
with me I'm beat buddy
well you're gonna finish this right
I guess I'm not done yet then I very
much love Rusty unfortunately the
mission end his signal disappears but to
be fair that isn't a confirmed death
especially for the man who once already
escaped from a deathly situation while
this happens we get to kill the ever
insufferable V2 snail
and then we head to the final fight air
remarks how we saved Rubicon when we
take out the xylem's ramjets ensuring it
will miss the coral but one more
obstacle remains a coral fueled Ibis AC
piloted by Handler Walter Walter is in
Hal 826 the last of the Ibis series and
it seems he has been put through some
sort of archivist re-education which is
talked about in some logs
Ayer says that whatever they did you're
in danger referring to something being
done to Walter and Walter also Raves a
bit incoherently and mentions the
corporation's orders Plus in the
previous Mission snail mentions how
Walter was recalcitrant to the last all
of this points to some attempt by
archivists to influence Walter to attack
us now we are trying to save the coral
which ostensibly helps archibus if they
have control of it but they may not know
that's what we're trying to do and they
likely see us as a threat regardless
especially since we are on the xylem
aiming to destroy all the coral and we
have killed their whole Squadron and
re-education or no Walter obviously
wants to ensure the coral goes boom it's
part of his plan so we fight we somewhat
defeat him but he still looks like he's
ready to fight in the ending cutscene
however he lowers his weapon speaking to
us to say
a friend
showing that he likely notices air
despite his own Fallen friends and their
wishes despite all the suffering he has
seen poor will bring about Walter
recognizes that we were able to find
something meaningful in the coral and he
can't bring himself to attack us anymore
his AC shuts off as the xylem enters the
atmosphere and we peace out
planet glassine is averted and air
remarks about how one day humanity and
coral will Thrive together
she says that we will find a path to
avoid collapse together and that's it
what the path is is not spelled out we
are basically just hoping that one day
some better option will show up and that
Coral won't Doom Humanity in the
meantime obviously the planet is not
burned but this ending does have a
similar kind of pushing the problem down
the line as the fires of Raven ending
being a liberator and keeping Rubicon
unharmed is a big difference but we
don't get much of a satisfying
conclusion to the issues of coral growth
and potential collapse we just hope that
air saying we can find a different path
is correct and maybe Walter's
recognition in US finding a friend in
Heir somewhat supports that and that it
might be a positive Choice while we get
a better taste in this ending plus we
keep Rusty on our side and maybe alive
which is a massive bonus we will need to
look at the third and final ending to
get a clearer picture
the final ending to armored Core 6 is
only available on your third playthrough
or Beyond in new game plus plus it
features the largest break from the mold
with the introduction of a new character
all mined and a different end sequence
previously all mind was just the
mercenary support system but this route
sees it gain or reveal some level of
sentience and act on its own it becomes
a third major player offering an
alternative to Walter and Carla's plan
instead of destroying the coral all mine
wants to initiate poor release letting
the coral grow throughout the Universe
the name of this ending is Aaliyah yakta
s which is a Latin phrase meaning the
dye is cast it is a saying attributed to
Julius Caesar when he crossed the
Rubicon the real River in Rome not this
fictional Mecha planet in the real world
Caesar's action of Crossing the Rubicon
with his army was a sign of war with
massive implications and consequences to
the state of Rome nowadays both phrases
Crossing the Rubicon and Alia yakta EST
have come to mean something like passing
the point of no return the die is cast
and there is no going back the
consequences whatever they are must be
faced and not only are there the obvious
connections between the phrase being
linked to Caesar Crossing the Rubicon
and the name of the game's Planet but
the full name of the planet is Rubicon
3. in Japanese the kanji for river is
this which looks both like a river and
the number three in Roman numerals plus
thumb domain tells us that The
Liberation Front full him is
all
for none of us shall cast the die all
these connections basically prove the
historical illusion to me and we will
see soon how this ending embodies the
phrase of its title how it goes farther
than the previous endings how it goes
past the point of no return now on to
the events of this ending the major
difference is that all mind warns us of
snail's plan to Ambush us at the end of
chapter 4. so instead of fighting Cell
240 we hunt him down off to the left G5
Iguazu also shows up at the fight
revealing that he was told we would be
here likely by all mine this Mexican
standoff ends of course with us
defeating both the Arrogant snail and
the mentally unwell Iguazu the next
chapter begins similarly we wake up
aboard the xylem interestingly all mind
wakes us up from stasis just as Walter
did at the beginning of the game com
says the same words
activating cerebral Coral control device
cerebral Coral control device is a
phrase to keep in mind given the themes
present in all endings about choice and
choosing for oneself we wake up and all
mind has us stop the xylem before it
passes the point of no return there's
that phrase again we fight through the
xylem and hear Carla and Walter discuss
us on the radio before all mind deals
with them we deal with chatty then we
reach the final stage for some reason we
and air make up the trigger for Coral
release possibly because we are the only
established contact between coral and
something that isn't Coral between that
and everything else Coral release is
still a somewhat unclear concept at this
point air sees it as the other way
mentioned in the Liberator of Rubicon
ending the path where humanity and coral
can Thrive together Walter and The
Observers likely see it as the collapse
a dooming of humanity all mine tells us
that we are the key in the trigger to
this event but then it oddly decides
that we need to be killed and then in an
even bigger surprise to me when I was
playing all mine boots up
iguazu-4.exe to do the killing job I've
been waiting
freelancer
the red gun's favorite mental ward
resident makes it clear that he couldn't
care less about all mind or its plan in
this epic AC space fight he still calls
us freelancer and says he only uploaded
his mind into all mind which he calls a
monster so he could have another chance
at killing us proving that he is the
most spite-driven character in existence
all mine tells us that you are the
trigger for Coral release
we will make you one with us so maybe it
doesn't trust that we will do the
release right or at all even though
we're going along with its plan and
Iguazu is quick to immediately remind
that the big plan is of negative value
to him he just wants our augmented ass
toast phase two sees air coming to the
fight piloting the echo AC and all guazu
busts out the heavy Mech plus two space
Fighters which is quite an imposing
level of Firepower for my little low AP
light Mech with dual shoddies Iguazu
notices that air is the ringing voice he
has been hearing throughout the game and
somehow wants to kill us even more now
eventually after telling all mind off
for the fifth time Iguazu resonates and
to some degree blocks out all mind and
air the fight becomes a pure one-on-one
obviously we eventually beat Iguazu and
in his dying beeps he reveals that he
envied us
freelancer
believe it at all
he couldn't handle that we were so dope
with the Dual zimmermans and that led
him to resent us so much that he joined
up with all mind for a shot at killing
us his Arena attack shows that he was
the same generation as us gen 4. so
seeing a similar old gen do so well in a
world of newer gens likely got to him
I'm sure in addition to Michigan's
constant screaming at him
after their defeat all mind worries
about their plan for the choral release
but we had already chosen to join them
in his ending so we are going to go
through with the release plan anyway
kind of makes the whole fight pointless
when we go forward with the release all
the same after wasting all mine if I had
to make a guess maybe all mine wants to
in some way control the release but we
don't have much evidence to claim that
a chain made of human links is easily
broken
in any case it's just kind of
thematically weird that we have this
whole big final boss fight because all
mine wants to absorb us to do coral
release and then we beat them and do
coral release anyway it's all just a bit
bemusing well we go ahead and Trigger
the choral release and basically spawn a
black hole at the vascular plant after a
coral sublimation we wake up in a
shallow pool of water surrounded by
other ACS the stars are specked with
signs of red coral
Ayer says Coral has been disseminated us
across the Stars
that it's everywhere she ends saying
that we should meet this new age
together and then delivers the most used
phrase in the game one of the first
words we hear on Rubicon and what was
said by com at the beginning of every
mission
main system activating combat that long
overall this ending highlights an
obvious choice beyond the dichotomy of
the first two endings but it also
doesn't really show Raven actively
choosing much for ourselves we basically
just go along with what all mine says
letting them kill Walter and Carla and
then the only reason we fight all mind
is because they try to kill us but we
then still do what they want and we're
planning to do all that plus the
similarity I noted of all mine waking us
up with the cerebral Coral control note
really puts a damper on the choosing for
yourself Vibes in this ending we don't
have enough information to really make a
clear judgment on if Coral release is
good or not either it did seem like
something had to be done considering
Coral survived getting burned by Ibis
and began growing again but many people
were worried about what a coral release
or collapse or widespread contact would
do we don't know if everyone in the
universe has been turned into Coral or
Coral ACS or just received a choral
contact Like Us in air or something else
is everyone in the universe and AC now
probably not but everyone around us
locally seems to be so maybe they are
and will Coral keep growing everywhere
it currently is that's hard to say too
maybe the release changed the properties
of coral and now it doesn't need to grow
so much or maybe now it will just have
an easier time growing to absorb the
known universe I do feel like the more
dire possibilities would have been noted
or worn by air since while she does want
to save the coral she also displays
Sympathy for the actions we take to
bring this about like going against
Walter as a sympathetic character she
doesn't do anything to indicate she is
big on tricking us she always asks us to
make a choice and hopes it will line up
with her own interests as Raven the
symbol of resolve of the will to choose
what one fights for it doesn't
necessarily feel like we embody our name
in this ending or really in either of
the other endings we kind of go along
with everyone's plans one way or another
we do choose who to go with whether to
fear Coral with Walter and Carla look
for another path towards Coral symbiosis
with air or go through with coral
release with or kind of despite all mind
we make some sort of choice one way or
the other and if the first two endings
just perpetuate a cycle or delay making
a proper Choice then this last ending
does cast the die in a way spreading the
coral throughout the Universe means
there's no going back like Caesar we
must March forward with his choice as
Raven we must meet this new age choose
what to fight for and take to the skies
in flight at least brumsoft gave us
quite the canvas to fly through in this
ending reflected in the pools of water
the whole world is our sky
there is much more lore in this game
hidden within the logs and voice lines
both about the characters of Rubicon 3
and also about the events referenced by
these endings like the fires of Ibis and
the story from Walter about The two
scientists if you want to learn more
about all that subscribe to the channel
thank you very much to my patrons for
supporting me and thanks to you for
watching I hope you enjoyed with that
see you in the next video
peace